hey everyone its Johanna here oh my god
the weather is getting coder and coded
day by day and coming from an extremely
hot country I do not like the call at
all but you know what this is the
perfect time to have soup as part of
your meals I am sure you have heard the
saying drink soup and stay sleep this is
very true especially if your soup is
packed full of healthy ingredients
because soup can be very low in calories
but they do keep you satisfied for a
very long time so what I'm going to
share with you are three of my favorite
soup recipes which I tend to have when
the weather starts to get bitterly cold
so let's start with my favorite being
Asian I love to have Chinese soup
noodles for my meals they are always up
in a large bowl they keep you satisfied
for so long and the amount you're eating
you would not believe that it's so low
in calories so what we're going to make
here is a bowl of chicken soup soup
noodles to keep you warm the ingredients
you need are one bundle of soba or
buckwheat noodles which is about 80 gram
four ounces of chicken boiled cook and
hand shredded into pieces 50 gram of
green leafy vegetables kill bog trial or
even cabbage one and a half of chicken
stock 3 cups of water one cup of garlic
crushed half of a small onion 1 teaspoon
of olive oil 1 tablespoon of goji
berries half a teaspoon of sesame oil
and one red chili finely sliced the
first step is to bring 2 pots of water
to boil once the water starts to boil in
one pot add your chicken and allow it to
cook
in the other part at yo soba noodles
another serve our noodles to cook for 5
to 10 minutes until it's cooked through
but still firm once your soba noodle is
cook we want to drain the water off
place the soba noodles into two bowls
tossed each bowl of soba noodles with
qty spoon of sesame oil and set it aside
once your chicken is cooked remove it
from the boiling water set it aside and
allow it to cool down cut your large pot
with 1 TSP of olive oil over medium-high
heat add your crushed garlic and onion
cook for 2 to 3 minutes until your onion
is slightly Brown add 3 cups of water
and your chicken stock and bring it to
boil under medium heat once the soup
starts to boil add your green leafy
vegetables and goji berries and allow
them to boil for another 5 minutes until
your vegetables is slightly soft once
your chicken has cooled down tie your
chicken into small shredded pieces
divide the soup evenly into two bowls
top it out with shredded chickens and a
little bit of fresh chopped chilies if
you like a little bit of extra kick this
one serving of chicken summer soup
noodles only has two hundred and
eighty-seven point 5 calories all these
ingredients used here can be bought in
an oriental supermarket so a turtle is a
Japanese noodle and it's a much
healthier option compared to egg noodles
or rice noodles it helps to promote
healthy bowel movements and it also
helps to reduce fat accumulation which
helps to work weight loss so if you can
use so maroudo's as for goji berries it
has recently become more and more
popular but in fact it's very commonly
used in Chinese cooking goji berries are
very high in antioxidant and it helps to
promote anti-aging maybe that's why cuba
in asia always look much younger it also
helps to reduce your appetite and
show your blood sugar level which helps
towards weight loss so if you can't add
a little bit of goji berries into your
cooking for the health benefits as for
chili I love to have spice in my food
spicy food helps to boost up your
metabolic rate which in return helps you
to burn more fat so if you like spicy
food if you can handle it add a little
bit of chili on to your noodles if you
can't you can always opt out of it do
try this bowl of chicken service soup
noodles either for your lunch or for
your dinner
are you having enough green vegetables
in a day or do you just not like the
green vegetables if so this creamy green
once the soup is for you it's so creamy
but guess what there is absolutely no
cream at all instead it's packed full of
green vegetables it's so good for your
body and even if you don't like green
vegetables you will like this soup you
have to try this the ingredients you'll
need are 1 TSP of olive oil 1 clove of
garlic crushed one large or two medium
leeks washed well and chopped 2 medium
zucchinis which is also known as
Japanese cucumbers in Asia chopped into
cubes 2 cups of water 1 chicken stock
100 grams of spinach I've used frozen
spinach thawed and salt and pepper to
taste in a part coat and heat 1 TSP of
olive oil under medium-high heat add the
crushed garlic leeks and zucchini and
cook for 3 to 4 minutes until the leeks
have softened season it with a little
bit of pepper and salt add 1 cup of
water and half a chicken stock and allow
your zucchini to cook until it's very
tender for 10 minutes don't forget to
stir every once in a while once in
tsukina is very tender remove the pot
from the heat
you can choose to transfer your zucchini
into a blender and blend it up or what
are you using is a hand blender
once a zucchini is a thick and creamy
add the remaining one cup of water and
half of a chicken stock and bring it
back to boil under medium heat and add
your thought spinach stir your thick
creamy soup and allow the ingredients to
cook for another four to five minutes
scoop it up and serve the recipe was for
four servings each serving only has 60
calories and you are getting the natural
creaminess from the zucchinis zucchini
is very low in calories it's high in
fiber and it has very high water content
so it's good for those of you who wants
to lose weight and it will keep your
body hydrated and keep you satisfied for
a long time if you want to avoid
overeating have a bowl of this creamy
green soup prior to your meal to keep
you full and help you to eat less or you
can have it with a slice of toast as
part of a meal or a snack and finally we
want to have chunky ingredients in our
soup packed full of fiber so what we
want to make is chunky vegetable barley
soup this large bowl of soup has less
calories than your Mars chocolate bar
and it would definitely give you more
energy and keep you satisfied for much
longer the ingredients you need are 4
cups of water 2 vegetable stocks 1 onion
chopped 1 large carrot chopped into
small cubes 200 grams of sweet potatoes
chopped into small cubes 150 grams of
broccoli 1/3 cup of uncooked / barley
which is about 75 gram 1 can of chopped
tomatoes I'm drained and 1 teaspoon of
paprika heat olive oil in a large pot
over medium heat and your onions and
lightly stir fry your onions until
slightly Brown then add your sweet
potato and carrots with 3 cups of water
and vegetable stock allow your potatoes
and carrots to cook
minutes after 10 minutes reduce the heat
slightly and add in your pearl barley
allow all the ingredients to cook for
another 30 to 40 minutes or until Bali
is tender and finally add in the 1 can
of chopped tomatoes broccoli and paprika
stir the ingredients and allow it to
simmer for another 10 minutes and serve
so here's a bowl of chunky vegetable
barley soup each serving only has 200
calories one Mars chocolate bar has over
200 calories so choose what is good for
your body and treat it right barley is a
very good food which should be used more
in our meals it's high in fiber and it
takes much longer to digest in our body
therefore it will keep us satisfied for
much longer as well whenever you feel I
stuck it on the chocolate bar put it
aside and have this bowl of chunky
vegetable barley soup instead
all these recipes are packed full of
nutrients which are good for your body
they are low in calories and they will
keep you satisfied for a long time it's
all about making choices these recipes
are much larger in quantity and low in
calories in comparison to the jugs so
treat your body right respect your body
and make the right choices for your
health for your weight there is
absolutely no reason not to eat clean
over the winter months so try this
recipe out let me know which is your
favorite in the comments below and enjoy
the cold weather for new Fitness food
and motivational videos please like
share and subscribe to my youtube
channel and website do follow me on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter to stay
connected with me thanks guys
you